hello大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
最近啊先感謝大家
因為我們周慕姿放心說的
YT訂閱破10萬了耶
所以呢我們今天這一集就是10萬訂閱
問與答
就是有一些朋友對我提出一些問題
我們也就趁這一集呢
來跟大家做一個回答哦
順便閒聊一下
首先呢就是有一些跟個人有關的問題
比如說有人問
顏值焦慮這件事有的時候還是會
例如說看到畫面的時候
覺得今天怎麼給我拍的那麼胖這樣子
也是會有這種心情
我記得我有過幾次
其實好像是素顏上節目沒有化妝
而且我錄完之後我才想到
哎呀今天忘記化妝了
好吧沒關係
就有時候會這樣
所以我覺得可能是因為我真的是p人
所以有時候在這件事情有點隨便
我覺得一定還是會有覺得不夠好看
或焦慮的時候
不過他可能比較不是會影響我這麼大的心情
我比較擔心的都是講的不夠好
或是今天內容有沒有幫助這樣
雖然聽起來真的很像好聽話
但的確我比較在意的是這個部分
那另外一個部分是
我覺得比較有趣的是每一個身份
我覺得算是都是我的一部分
某方面來說我還蠻滿意現在的生活的
原因是因為我好像想做的事情
都有很盡力的去做
所以最喜歡比較難分辨
可是我最希望的是
我可以不用只被心理師的這個身份
給束縛 這可能是
我最近幾年對我最期待的事情
這個朋友問的問題說
心理學相關的書真的是很多欸
我實在是不得不說
如果是目前
大家在線上會看到的一些心理學的書
可能說不定有六七成我可能都有看過
最近我蠻喜歡的一本書是
有一本書叫服從權威
他在談權威議題
而且他很好玩的地方是
他也有談到之前的那個監獄測驗
然後這個監獄測驗本身代表意義
以及權威對我們的影響為什麼那麼大
甚至連同這個權威的部分
我們其實可以就是去理解一些
關於像是邪教團體啊
或是宗教團體啊的一些狀態
我覺得這本書蠻好看的
然後另外我最近還有在讀一本
就是韓國的犯罪側寫師權一容
他寫的解讀殺人犯
也有談論到一些心理學的東西
但是呢
他主要其實是用比較社會學的角度
去討論犯罪這件事情怎麼發生
那如果要預防犯罪的話要怎麼做
我自己非常覺得非常喜歡他用的角度
跟他切入討論的主題
所以我也蠻喜歡這本書
而且很容易看
所以如果有興趣的朋友
可以參考看看
另外我最近還有在讀另外一本書
叫修復家庭創傷
修復家庭創傷這一本書
它其實是在講
就是我們的創傷
還有一些情緒的來源
其實很容易是以一個家庭為單位
而不是用個人為單位
所以有一些創傷它其實是會遺傳的
這我們在心理學會講是代間傳遞
這本書它本身呢
在用比較
系統的觀念去看很多創傷的形成
還有如果要做治療的話
可能必須以家庭為單位來做治療
因為很多創傷跟互動有關
我覺得這個部分非常的值得
大家如果有興趣的話可以去讀一下
不過因為最後這本書
跟第一本服從權威都稍微
如果你是比較不習慣看很多字的人
也許你會覺得
在閱讀上稍微有一點點難度
解讀殺人犯這本書
我覺得就是相對比較好讀的
大家可以先去書店參考看看
這個問題真的是大哉問
不過因為我們常常會討論這件事情
最最最重要跟最簡單的方式
就是請把注意力放在你自己身上
試著去更瞭解你自己是個怎麼樣的人
喜歡什麼事情
然後什麼事情會不舒服
儘可能不要用太批評的方式
去對待自己
我覺得這件事情會幫助你
越來越能夠理解你是一個怎麼樣的人
然後建立屬於你自己的規則
我覺得這是一個非常好的方式
可以試試看
另外呢
其實我有好幾個我自己有興趣的店家
然後就是有點像是我網路上看
覺得欸他好可愛
我就會買下來
下次我看看能不能談到一些合作
然後有些優惠我再來分享給大家
好不好
另外就說
這個學妹問的問題
政大讀書最有名的就是那個風雨走廊
每天都風雨啊
一天到晚都下雨
然後那個那個淹水的時候
那個斜坡就刷
然後還有我們當年的時候
我不知道現在還有沒有了
我覺得最痛苦的地方就是
禮拜一早上8點
必修英聽課
在超山上的英聽教室
那還有什麼有趣的地方
應該是店
比如說我們以前有一家燒臘店
叫殺人魔王
大家都會去那邊買燒臘
然後那個老闆非常的有趣
老闆對我很好
每次我都就是跟老闆甜言蜜語說老闆
你們東西好好吃哦
然後我就多得一個滷蛋
從那個時候開始
養成我會去稱讚老闆
煮的東西很好吃的一個習慣
就是政大
其實蠻有趣的
但比較辛苦
真的是他是一個
只要過辛亥隧道
天氣就會變得很差
但空氣很好
這是一件好事
接下來的問題就是問
我想一想啊
我不知道是不是所有的P人都這樣
我先我先講
是我這種P人
我很討厭被規定
什麼時間要做什麼事情
但是我的工作
又一定要規定什麼時間做什麼事情
所以某方面我會盡可能安排
把工作的事情
就是儘量集中在某個時段
或是集中在同一天
這的確是
我讓自己
一直處在工作狀態的一個方法
另外一個部分
就是會有一定要做的事情
可是一定要做的事情對於P人來說
又很討厭被限制
所以我常常會遇到一個狀況
就是我會盡可能讓我一定要做的事情
固定在什麼時候把它做完
那這個時候我就會
想要鼓勵一下大家
因為我不知道
會不會有很多人跟我一樣哦
有的時候你有一定要做的事或很想做的事
可是你會發現你很容易會想要打混
因為打混這件事情就是手機
還有你的就是Netflix
那些要吸引你的大腦注意力
實在太容易了
他們可以產生很多多巴胺
所以到最後
你要努力讓自己的注意力
可以回到自己想做的事情身上
就是你要先熬過前面15分鐘
很好玩是你前撐前面15分鐘之後
你會開始覺得這件事情有趣起來
然後你就比較能夠把這件事情
可能做完一個小時
一個半小時
把它做完之後你再去做休閒
嚴格來說
我還是一個比較喜歡先苦後甘的人
因為我覺得一直沒有做那個事情
可是那個事情在那邊你會一直焦慮
這件事情會讓我覺得很不舒服
所以我其實大部分時候
還是會希望先把那個事情做完
我覺得這件事情蠻難說的
有很多書我覺得對我的影響蠻大
不過如果真要這樣講的話
我曾經有一次在節目上分享過
我國中的時候讀丹諾自傳
這件事情對我的影響很大
因為他是一個人權律師
我覺得那時候對我印象最深刻的
是他聊到廢死
我記得
我在讀他前面的所有章節的時候
我跟他的想法跟他的思考
我覺得都是同步的
我非常非常認同
我覺得他好棒
我好崇拜他
我想要成為他這樣的人
我一直保持這樣的心情
直到他講到廢死這件事
完全衝擊到我的價值觀
那是讓我第一次去思考
如果有一個人
他大部分的想法都跟你一樣
可是他提出了一個
跟你根本上完全不一樣
可是對你來說
又是很重要的一個價值觀
的時候你要怎麼消化這件事
你要完全認同這個人
還是你要對這個人失望
覺得天哪
虧我這麼崇拜你
結果你在這件事情
想法居然跟我完全不一樣
還是你要重新去思考這件事情
我跟他想法不一樣
為什麼他對我的影響是什麼
為什麼那個時候
一個這麼讓我崇拜的人
他提出了一個
跟我現在腦中完全不同的想法
我會這麼的吃驚
這麼的震撼
最後
當我發現他跟我想法不一樣的時候
我是要馬上決定要順從
要否定還是
我可不可以先讓這件事情存而不論
先留在那裡重新去思考
這件事情本身代表的意義是什麼
面對一個你所肯定的權威的價值觀
衝擊這件事情對我的影響蠻大的
因為他讓我在後來想很多事情
跟做很多事情的時候
即使對方跟我是大部分想法是類似
甚至他可能是一個我是很喜歡
或是我是很肯定的人
我們根本上
還是會有一些價值觀是不同的
我變得越來越能接受這件事
接下來有人在問職業的問題
這個問題也算是大哉問
你要有一定的經濟能力
因為現在要成為心理師
你前面唸書
還有實習
然後寫論文
如果你想要好好的
把這個學科學好的話
你會花很多
時間在學科上
你沒有辦法花很多時間賺錢或幹嘛
所以你有一定的經濟能力
會讓你在學習的這個過程中
壓力不會那麼大
另外有一個狀況是
畢業的諮商心理師真的很多
可是目前看起來臺灣的諮商心理師的
我說的是專任的職缺
沒有想像中的這麼大
我覺得有時候是職場環境
不一定跟得上
就是大家畢業的速度
另外回到人的本質上
成為心理師
我覺得你可能要有對人基本的同理心
你對人有興趣
而且你有同理心
不只要有興趣
要有同理心
同理心跟同情不一樣
同理心意思是你對於人你有興趣
而且你覺得你對於換位思考
然後跟站在對方的立場思考
他為什麼會理解這個事情
你的這個方法跟狀態
對你來說是容易的
你不會說看到一個人一個狀態
你就很容易覺得啊
他好可憐哦
或者是你馬上就覺得說啊
他為什麼不改變
不管是覺得他好可憐
或是覺得他不改變
我們其實都還是站在我們的立場
去看對方的狀態
因此同理心跟同情很不一樣
不是說哦
我看到他很可憐就代表我很有同理心
不是的是我
我知道他的狀態
我知道他為什麼這樣
所以我願意留有一個空間
去理解一個人
然後一定要可以接受
就是你在訓練的過程中
可能是需要花一點時間跟吃一點苦的
然後不要太急
因為我覺得現在大家都會很希望
可以趕快被看見
可是心理師是一個
他可能內在工作是比較多的
一個工作
所以我覺得那中間的平衡很需要拿捏
再來就是說
其實某方面他是一個很權威的工作
也就是說你去探索一個人的新的東西
是別人把他的脆弱交到你手上
所以有的時候
你有能力去做到這件事情的時候
我們對自己其實會很有信心的
但是你如果太把注意力放在你對別人
是可以做到什麼事情
你有能力解決什麼問題
你很厲害
這件事情
他有時候會讓你沒有辦法
跟著一起工作的對象
走向他的世界
跟他的心裡的這個重點
你會帶著他走向就是另外一個地方
可能是你想去的地方
我覺得這個是比較不容易的
然後能夠持續為自己的心理工作
對自己有了解的這個部分
的確我覺得一直都是
要成為一個心理師
比較需要就是花時間的地方
所以跟大家分享
我覺得可能是因為諮商工作
是你在裡面會感覺到最多
人的真實
掙扎脆弱
還有感動的那個部分
我覺得那個人心的感動
是沒有任何一個東西可以替代
你會在那個瞬間
當你跟對方的心思在一起的時候
你會感覺到一個
我很難用言語描述的東西
所以諮商工作最迷人的東西
絕對不是大家想像說我們個案變好了
或者是你做了什麼事情
個案覺得你好棒
最感動的時候
真的是在那個瞬間
你跟個案的心是在一起的那一個感受
是人跟人之間的關係的那個部分
很令人感動
然後那個是做這個
工作我覺得對我來說
最就是覺得最有能量的時候吧
所以
這是為什麼我很喜歡諮商工作原因
哦還有人問
其實老實說
我覺得每個人有每個人的狀態
也就是說
應屆考上的人也不是每個人都長一樣
出去外面工作過
回來也不是每個人都長一樣
更何況也有那種完全不是本科系進來
像我就是
所以與其問說會不會比較弱
倒不如說
你會知道你應屆考上你就擁有什麼
跟你少了什麼
你越清楚你少什麼
你以後去工作上越往那個部分打磨
或者那個部分對你來說就不會是弱點
更甚者
說不定那一個你覺得你不夠的地方
你根本工作上不一定需要用也有可能
所以我覺得最終還是必須回到
你夠不夠了解你自己
你知道你有什麼
你沒有什麼
你需要什麼
你現在要前往的方向
他需要你先去建立跟存
好的工具是什麼
最後還是提醒大家
不要急著跟別人比較
你要先清楚你自己有什麼
把自己能做的事情做到最好
然後缺的東西有需要慢慢的補起來
其實就是這樣而已
好的我發現呢
大家對我的問題最多
其實是對心理師的身份哦
所以不知道是不是因為大家
現在很多人想成為心理師
不過還是蠻鼓勵大家
就是說如果你有想要成為心理師
先去旁聽或是先去看一下相關的書籍
你讀不讀的下
去問一下相關的工作
就是實務經驗的人
他們的工作形態
對你來說是你可以接受的嗎
以及大部分的心理師在畢業之後
其實還是大量的進修
不管是找督導也好
或者是去修課也好
其實那個花費的成本跟時間
都非常非常高
可能這一行
沒有大家想象中的這麼的光鮮亮麗
可是如果你純粹只是因為你很喜歡人
你對這個工作很有興趣
我覺得的確是可以藉由更多的瞭解
然後去評估看看他到底適不適合你
好的謝謝
今天大家就是對於周慕姿放心說
還有對於我的一些問題
那希望今天的回答呢
有回答到大家想要聽到的東西
那麼周慕姿放心說
我們下次見拜拜